that's like that's like Kevin Durant
always says man I just want a hoop like
I'd be I would be hooping if I wasn't
getting paid like it's my love you know
what I'm saying for sure
um
music wise what do you got on the way
you are you because I know you're you're
you got the battle [__] going crazy you
just had it did you just battle or you
were at the Battle this weekend did you
have a battle this weekend no I just was
hosting I'm hosting a lot of these
events um hosted the rbe event a smack
event just hosted this event create for
you that they put together
so I missed the podcast I'm doing media
I'm hosting to get more attention on
battle rap to make it better for the
battle rappers and for myself when I do
finally get back in battle
but um I ain't set up on the actual
battle the name yet to tell you but
um I'm in negotiations with a lot of
people so hopefully I have like at least
two battles this year hopefully fire but
what about are you or like on the music
tip are you working on anything
oh yeah my new project I feel like is
the best project of my life like this
new music I got this new wave I'm on
it's like I'm happy with it and I can't
wait to drop it I'm just
um independent and doing everything from
the muscle and because I feel so good
about this project I just wanted to be
perfect so I got some little finishing
touches I got to put on it before I
release it but it's coming ASAP and it's
crazy I got the single already done we
gonna shoot the record of my um new
project today with Fred money out here
shout out to Fred money man yeah
it's um but um
I'm about to shoot another single real
soon grinding when we go back to Atlanta
but I think me living out a land and
being in that new environment is what
got me like still spitting bars and
lyrical but the bounces and the flows
and the the bag I'm in is just like
different than you would expect to hear
from me especially a dude that's been in
it as long as me so I can't wait what's
your relationship with Swiss like these
days
still the same man that's my brother
um we not connected to hang out like we
used to you know what I'm saying but
people grow still communicating still
take still work you still give me advice
and we still like family got a lot more
connections other than me and swiss like
me and his pop me and his uncle's me and
a bunch of people that's connected with
Swiss like and I mean it's so many years
that I've been tied up that I can't
really Separate Myself yo am I tripping
or was there a point in time you were
wrong with Carmelo Anthony
um yeah
um after
I was I was with Swiss beats and G
records right and I got um 1G records
fell apart was the last the last time
was bars on Jay right yeah yeah but when
like J Records broke down and Sony took
over and started doing all that stuff I
was out my major deal you know what I'm
saying because it was no more G records
right
so that's when I felt the time to be
free I could go in the independent
Direction and I mean but
um
so if I was gonna go in the independent
Direction I wanted to still do it big
but I needed investors so I felt like
basketball [__] was getting wild money
some of them be wasting it and throwing
it away it's not like I'm trying to blow
a lot of money I just need a certain
amount like if I was with a label to
make this project make sense so I
started thinking like yo I know
basketball players I know people
um
told mellow the plan wrote it out in
paperwork presented it to him and his
legal team and that's how we did the
deal but I wasn't signed to Mellow like
um people thought like in a traditional
way yeah it was more like him like a
record label like he was my CEO and I
was signed he was an investor exactly
yeah that's what it was oh that's dope
shout out to Mellow it was so many
rappers who had or Amar'e Stoudemire had
a label
when uh who else
mellow KD had a label Katie's working on
an album with 38 special and um and
Ransom right now it's crazy when you see
guys like like uh I think all these
Sports dudes let's get into the bag
shaft labels man why not no make these
artists you know
be able to get loans or invest like you
know get the opportunity to get the
loans they need to be successful from
different places other than what's
available now